how's it going everybody in this video
today I'm going to be talking about a
question that I think a lot of people
have been wondering about and that is
why did Thor need storm breaker in
Avengers infinity war I think a lot of
people were thinking well in Thor
Ragnarok we learned that Thor doesn't
actually need a hammer he's not the god
of hammers he's the god of thunder and
it's true his powers do not originate
within the hammer they originate within
himself but that doesn't necessarily
mean that he's stronger without a hammer
than he is with a hammer
you have to keep in mind that in thor
ragnarok having a hammer wasn't an
option
hello already destroyed Millner and she
was about to kill everyone in Asgard as
well Thor did not have time to get a new
weapon
Odin didn't necessarily tell him that he
is stronger without a hammer all he told
him was that he is still Thor Odinson
without the hammer so let's talk about
some reasons why Thor needed storm
breaker in Avengers infinity war but
first if you're new to this channel be
sure to hit that subscribe button so you
could stay up to date and all things
related to Avengers infinity war and
Avengers 4 the first reason is that it's
psychologically made him stronger
Thor thought that the hammer made him
stronger so therefore it did make him
stronger in Thor's mind him and me
linear or one they were a team and
losing mule near was kind of like losing
a part of himself and therefore Thor
getting a new hammer is being complete
again and he regains his confidence
which we all know is key to a fight the
second reason is that each remade the
Infinity Gauntlet for Thanos therefore
it is most likely made of Ihram metal
and is basically indestructible unless
you have another weapon that is made of
metal that can destroy the Infinity
Gauntlet aka storm breaker
the third reason is the magic that it
had and could channel through it I think
it's safe to say that Loki has always
been the more magically inclined brother
Thor always used magical energy through
his hammer Mjolnir Muller gave him the
ability to deflect and block magical
attacks and energy and it helped him
reach these powers more easily again the
power
from within Thor but the hammer helps
him channel these powers more easily
reason number four a more concentrated
and focused energy attack usually equals
more power instead of just brawling
all-out and having your energy be
distributed to multiple sources taking
that and harnessing it and put it into
one source and one attack that makes it
much stronger and as Odin says in thor
ragnarok that's what the hammer does for
Thor reason number five it gave Thor a
tactical and strategic advantage Thor
can throw this hammer he can use it to
fly he can deflect energy and use energy
beams as well he can shoot lightning out
of it and he can throw it and have the
lightning hit multiple people at one
time basically it seems a lot better to
have it in a fight than to not have it
and somewhat fallen in the same category
as tactical and strategic advantage is
number six comfort and familiarity Thor
has been fighting with a hammer for
1,500 years he may be a little uneasy
going into a battle with that one number
seven the ability to summon the Bifrost
as each restated storm breakers magic is
so powerful that it could even summon
the Bifrost and it did that is how Thor
rocket and Groot got to earth and just
in the nick of time and I'm not sure of
any other way with the exception of the
space stone that you can travel across
the galaxy in a matter of seconds so
much needed number eight efficiency Thor
needed Stormbreaker so he could channel
his thunder and energy more efficiently
even Odin had Goong near his spear and
even hella using Mjolnir before Thor did
by the way where is gun year does
anybody know anyways number nine Thor is
more skilled with a weapon than he is
hand-to-hand combat again he spent 1500
years fighting with weapon and even in
Thor Ragnarok when he went to fight the
Hulk he used weapons and not to mention
in the beginning of infinity war granted
we didn't see it on screen he already
lost the Thanos in hand-to-hand combat
essentially in a fight it's usually
better to have a weapon then to not have
one and final reason number 10 Thor was
not used to his full powers yet and did
not know how to fully control the
they know showed up let's say 30 minutes
to an hour after thorn everybody left as
guard he only had one battle so far
without his hammer and he didn't even
defeat hella he really had no time to
develop or figure out who he is without
a hammer before Thanos showed up so he
had to figure out a way to use and
control these new powers that he's
developed in a way that he was familiar
with already and that is through storm
breaker so those are the reasons that
Thor needed storm breaker and Avengers
infinity war because it would make him
more confident more focused and
controlled more dangerous made him to
where he could deflect the energy of the
Infinity stones so he could fly and
because he's Thor Thor needs a hammer
it's who he is so there you have it I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
click that thumbs up button for me and
be sure to let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and be sure to
subscribe to my channel for more
information on Avengers infinity war
Avengers for all things Marvel DC and
superhero thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you